what I did love you Tanya earlier was  your dog your dog was the first person  who actually noticed something was wrong  with you yes yeah so she was I'm this  amazing dog  Bowie she's a German Shepherd like David  Bowie and she's named doctor and she  would obsessively sort of sniff right  here on my right side and so it made  sense when I got diagnosed then when I  got back from surgery she again was kind  of like right in this area and then when  I had my first chemo she was just she  would sniff my entire body up and down  and she was always protective before but  she's become just this crazy protective  dog she is she it's hard to get close to  me when she's around